the TV show Ghost Whisperer who or the
Show creator well here's how that
usually the show came about I had been
doing a lot of movies for CBS at that
time
and I had no interest in TV series I
didn't want to direct episodes you know
just well I didn't have disdain for it
it just wasn't something I was
interested in I just like the idea of
the same characters all the time
so um I always avoided it and there was
an executive who I liked very much named
Bella bajaria at CBS and she called me
one day and said that she had just met
this woman and I think she met her
through James Van Prague the famous
psychic and uh
this woman had been brought to L.A
because her Talent is that she can make
ghosts or haunting you go away
she can see them if they're Earthbound
and she can convince them to cross over
and so there were people at CBS who were
having problems that they felt were
being caused by ghosts in their house
and when James told them about this
woman Marianne who lived in Ohio they
brought her in and apparently it was
very successful she immediately
identified who their ghosts were and got
rid of them so uh Bella called me said
look whether you believe any of this or
not I think there might be a series here
there might be something about this
woman and you should meet her
and so I was in LA and and Marianne was
because she had just had cleared their
houses
so I sure I'll be happy to meet her and
I we met at a Starbucks in Studio City
and I walked in and I'm expecting to see
some like ethereal looking you know
person but instead is this very solid
down to earth
just salt of the earth kind of woman and
with her husband it was an ex-marine you
know buzz cut tattoos you know and I sat
there and talked with him and she was so
wonderful and kind and funny and
good-hearted and you know wasn't full of
herself didn't feel like she had the
answers to all the world's problems you
know her thing is she grew up being able
to see ghosts and she learned how to
make them go away
and so I was I really became fascinated
by this because of course I love horror
I love Gothic horror
um and so I asked her I said well so you
just see ghosts all the time
is yeah I can't turn it off she said I
try not to let them sometimes know that
I see them because then they bother me
you know so they want something from me
so I said well how about right now
and so yeah there's three ghosts right
here in the Starbucks and she's gonna
explain me like that guy over there I
think it's probably his mother she's
looking at him she doesn't seem to be
very approving and this person over here
I think it might be his son and it was
kind of really you know like the hair on
my neck kind of went up a little bit and
that scene by the way is in the pilot of
the the show and so I drove away
thinking wow so you know Gothic horror
ghost stories with character-driven
drama I thought this could be a great
way to meld those two passions of mine
and so I called executive back I said
yeah I'd love to write this pilot and
you know who knows and so we made a deal
and I wrote the pilot and I thought you
know I'll write this and then I'll go on
back to my regular life making movies
because you know what's the chance of a
pilot being mean
and I've never written a pilot it'll be
very interesting so I wrote the pilot
and they really liked the pilot and they
said let's shoot it
okay wow so well I've never made a pilot
it'll be fun to do a pilot it'll never
go to series because they're you know
the mortality weight is huge in these
things
so I shot the pilot and they said okay
we like this pilot let's do 13 episodes
and then I really got panicky I thought
God I have to do this 13 more times you
know come up with stories ah how can I
do this
but we did it and we got a great writing
staff together and Marianne was very
helpful she you know consulted a lot of
things it was an opportunity for me to
really deal with all my fears about
death and and
um grief and loss and that's how I
approached the show it was it was my
chance to work through all my issues
about this stuff
and at the same time to try to
um treat death in a way that could maybe
give somebody some hope maybe there is
something a little more than we we know
out there
and so I can really turned on by it and
and that's you know then I little did I
know I would spend the next five years
of my life basically making that making
that show and it was a wonderful
experience but a great cast there was um
I mean everyone got along there was no
drama behind the camera it was just a
really wonderful experience and I loved
it as a filmmaker
because of the speed you know I would
get an idea
go home write it and I could literally
see it on the air in four weeks
and you know it was a hit show people a
lot of people watched it and we got a
lot of amazing and very moving feedback
from people
and um
it was just a tremendous experience and
we did one episode because I was trying
to work out my fear of flying oh I I
still don't quite get flight I don't
understand how we can sit in this
kerosene filled tube and hurdle through
space at 600 miles an hour and somehow
we know where we're going we land in
this exact spot you know five hours
later I just don't get how that works
all wire works and so every time in a
plane I think at some point you know God
that's going to look down and say what I
think they're doing they can't do that
you know
so
um I fly all the time as we all we have
to but I I'm terrified of it so I did an
episode where a plane crashed in their
town
and Melinda comes out of her store and
sees this building smoke you know from
the where the crash was and then coming
up the street are 150 ghosts who just
came off this plane and so it was a
double episode that we did and it was
fantastic for me in every way because I
could I had I could through the other
characters I could deal with not only
the fear of flying but you know this
whole idea of mass loss and
and uh grieving and how do you let it go
and all that stuff and so they were very
successful episodes I'm still afraid of
flying
um but it was a good example of why I
love working that show I could just work
out so much of this stuff
were there certain areas that she
couldn't go into because it was just too
many ghosts and it was too tragic for
her not really I mean there were moments
where she felt the heaviness of tragedy
and you know we should be depressed I'm
talking about the real Marianne yeah and
uh but for the most part
um you know and there was when she
actually crossed somebody over
there was really no yeah she did it all
sort of mentally
she would just kind of go into this you
know she'd just be quiet and she's
communicating with this ghost mentally
and she okay he's gone
yo what so on the show of course we had
to kind of
pretty that up a bit you know we had to
have a we never really did the light or
anything but we always did interesting
ways for people to cross over and and
look magical and fun sometimes scary
um but uh it was just uh just that's one
of the highlights of my life doing that
doing that show is it still available
for people to watch I know the series is
no longer it is it's on Hulu I think
um it's all over and it's playing all
over the world I mean there's never a
moment where it's not playing somewhere
it's amazing it's like 127 different
countries people really loved it and I
think that the reason it struck a chord
it's not because it's such a brilliant
show or you know
um it's not art but I think that
um after 9 11 we came on in 2005 so we
weren't that far out
but I really think there was a hunger
out there
for Hope and to try to find uh some way
to believe that there's more beyond that
there's maybe I think it just gave
people an appetite for wanting to
believe that there's just more than just
what we're seeing here and I really
think that that's what struck certainly
a lot of the letters we got spoke to
that yeah
is pretty great can you take us into the
writer's room for Ghost Whisperer so how
would you structure different episodes
how would the writers work with each
other well that's an interesting
question because
I never quite got comfortable in the
writer's room environment it was one of
my I you could probably say one of my
failings as a showrunner I suppose but
having been a solitary writer for 25
years of my career at the time I started
that show it suddenly became really
difficult to sit in a room we had a
great staff smart we had playwrights we
had really smart people in that room and
to be able to instantly identify ideas
that's good that's bad that's good
that's bad that's good I found that
really difficult because I I just kind
of I'm used to the page and the keyboard
and thinking through everything not
necessarily slowly but on my own without
anybody watching the process you know or
being asked to deliver an instant
verdict on something
so I I found it really difficult
um I I listened to someone's idea well
that's great that's a great idea and
somebody else has it that that's even
better yeah oh that's fantastic and I'd
be confused like yeah I wouldn't I would
always have to take all the stuff and go
back to my desk and try to make my own
sense of it so after a while what we did
uh was
um we would convene in the writer's room
at the beginning of the season and lay
out basic big things we wanted to do
in terms of themes and also just story
arcs and who where we're going to bring
this character through by the end of the
season what we want them to be here
um and then when we started getting
comfortable if we had scripts to start
writing we would just go back to our own
offices and start writing and then
basically I would then work with the
writers one-on-one
which I was much more comfortable with
than being in the atmosphere of a
free-for-all kind of room
and you know the network would get upset
about this they were like what it's not
the way we do it you know it's the way I
do it and it seems to be working and the
writers seem to like it they seems like
having the one-on-one attention and and
you know if they collectively came up
with a problem or something to solve
they were free to convene the room
without me if I wasn't there if I might
have been directing or something
and then they could call on the power of
the room to solve a thorny plot Problem
but you know pretty much I worked
um you know kind of one-on-one
and then in the third season uh
I was getting a little bit anxious to
move on I felt like it got to the point
where I would be on a set and I could no
longer think of a different way to shoot
the set you know I've been in this
kitchen now how many times so I was
anxious to try to do different things
although I still love the show
um so we brought in a great show in her
name PK Simmons
um and he and I worked together in
season three and then he took over in
season four and five and I had a great
opportunity then of just writing and
directing a couple of episodes of season
you know they would just say which ones
you want to do okay I'm going to do
these and that was really great because
I was free then of the the note sessions
for the network and uh you know I could
just be a filmmaker and make these
movies and then develop other things I
wanted to develop
um and PK took the show in really
interesting directions and and uh and it
continued to do really well in the
ratings and you know the transition was
pretty seamless
um and so you know it was a five-year
run and uh it changed my life in many
ways and
um you know the profits from that show
helped me make my short films which I'm
really grateful for
and I've made friendships on the show
that you know to this day I still
maintain and uh it was it was a very
golden time as a filmmaker who loves the
process of being on the set I love
directing I love working with the Actors
and The Crew I love the cameras I love
everything about it so to be able to do
it so often you know was just so great
um because you know TV we were making 22
of these a year you know 22 hours a year
so I could I could be directing a bunch
of them it was a great experience lots
of fun
but then in terms of the writing it
sounds like because you were used to
being a solitary writer standing at a
desk or whatever your process was that
that yeah I think that would be
difficult for a lot of people a room
with many different agendas even if
everything's harmonious just to have so
much going on yeah you know I hate to
say it but so the Democracy of it uh
through me
um because you know as a solitary writer
you just used to just you get your own
ideas you vet them you throw them out
you accept them but now you suddenly
have to learn how to accept new ideas
and and you know for a series it's
really important you gotta you can't
really you can't be just one person's
Vision really to make a good series you
need people to bring different skill
sets to the table and we had that on
Ghost Whisper and I feel like we made
good use of that even though we had a
rather unusual structure but when PK
came in you know he he had grown up in
the room system and so for season three
four five we had the room and everybody
you know it was great and you know the
room is also a trap because you've got a
room full of eight really bright people
and you know you start telling stories
and it's funny and you know half a day
goes by and your sides heard from
laughing so much but oops we didn't
really solve episode three did we you
know so there was a lot of that too a
lot of great food I'm sure too yes too
much food really difficult and in uh we
were at Universal and uh
you know what's what's crazy about
Universal is that the tram you know the
the tourist tour and I can tell all you
tourists they do go through everywhere
where movies are really being made
because we would just have to watch
right outside the writer's room the
train would go by and here's the famous
room where all these TV shows are
written yeah so one of our writers
Catherine Butterfield developed a tram
theater
where you know they'd be bored and they
would when they saw tram coming they'd
go outside on the little sidewalk
outside our writer's room and they would
start arguing with you they start a
fight they start you know and something
to give the the people something
to look at when they walk fine so you
know the highlight of their day was tram
theater so this is the kind of thing
that could happen in the room
did every episode of Ghost Whisperer
have the same structure yes that was you
know one thing about CBS and again it
was a funny story because when I sold
even though they came to me with this
notion I had to Fashion a pitch and I
have to go back to them and say okay
here's how I would do this show and they
said great do it and and uh we're one of
the top Executives said to me was what
we love about your pitch is is that it's
not like anything else we have on the
air I said great and then we started the
development process during which they
made it as much as possible like every
other show
it was just funny it's like they can't
help themselves it's like this knee-jerk
reaction
um however having said that you also
have to respect the fact that at least
then I'm not sure about now but then CBS
was the top Network they were knocking
out of the park
so you can't argue with that kind of
success someone in somewhere knows what
they're doing
so I try to have a good attitude about
it and I want to have a successful show
so I took their notes and we tried to
make them as much as possible doable and
not violate you know what we felt the
show could stand for and and we were
pushed back sometimes and they'd back
off if we made a good argument for them
they weren't just dictatorial about it
um but it was kind of interesting how it
became a more of a procedural about how
to solve a mystery every week uh and
that's that's a CBS brand really is
every show they do whether it's CSI
whatever it is it's a procedural so that
was the biggest kind of template that
they uh kind of uh imposed on it was
that we had to stick to this thing but I
tried to encourage them to let us do
some serialization where we could have a
character shows up in this episode and
then again four episodes later uh and
continue their story over an arc of
episodes and they resisted that at first
nope we want close-ended episodes we
don't want a situation where someone
watches episode five and they didn't see
episode two or three and we want them so
they've missed nothing you know they
will know that they're watching this and
they can just pick up where they left
off
I said yes I get that but it's dull you
know so can we just for the for those
who might want something a little more
can we add a little thing in here and
they finally started letting us do it do
it just little by little we're bringing
these characters who were either ghosts
or represented the Dark Side of ghosts
and and it became more interesting for
all of us than to make the show because
we did we had a little more going on
than just a simple
story had to be solved you know in 40
minutes every week
did viewer feedback factor in to
different things in the story I don't
remember ever having that happen
um we've got a lot of great touching you
know we got a letter once from a
Gravedigger
and this guy was saying how he sees this
grief all the time at cemeteries
um and he's just this invisible person
no one really pays attention to the
gravedigger but uh and you know I always
want to do an episode like that I don't
know I'm not sure why we never did but
uh it was a very movie letter and he was
talking about how much he loved the show
and how much it meant to him emotionally
and it helped him deal more positively
with some of the things that he saw just
in his job everything you know kids
weeping and they're you know so we got a
lot of moving we got another letter once
from uh this an older man
and he was saying how much he loved
watching the show with his wife and he
would hold her hands about the whole
show but as the letter went on it became
clear that his wife was dead and not
with him anymore and so he had this you
know so we we get these letters that
would just give us Goosebumps and it
would be loved however the things that
did affect oftentimes which you know was
never fun for us you know CBS uh
we're often have a knee-jerk reaction to
something that would happen on one of
their other shows
so for instance you know if if um a
character behaved in a certain way in an
episode of The Mentalist or something
else that was on then
uh and the ratings dropped a fraction of
a point during that scene
they come back okay now in your show
your next episode you got someone doing
this can't do that uh we dropped on that
one we can't
and be like come on you know but we have
to respect that and do that you know and
I always felt that was a little bit and
I envied shows that had enough episodes
in the can
where they they they had enough lead
time so they couldn't really respond
that quickly but we oftentimes were only
a couple weeks ahead of airing when we
were shooting so you know so
um that was that was the only thing that
outside influenced that you know really
affected sometimes the direction of our
show so policies across the board so if
saying a certain word or whatever
scenario lost the audience or offended
them in some ways right you just need
your Panic thing of like oh can't do
that yeah
and there's another process too
um with our focus groups which I think
is probably responsible for more dull
television than any other single thing
and you have to sit there and you're in
this room behind a mirror and they've
got a test audience
and already you're in trouble because
the test audience they're from La half
of them are already in the business they
don't want to admitted crazy
and so there they've got a dial and all
they have to do is when they like
something turn the dial this way when
they don't like it turn it that way
so we'd have a scene in the pilot where
the two main characters were arguing
your important scene conflict arguing
and they don't like it because they you
know it's an argument and these people
love each other they shouldn't be
fighting
but you get you know you you gotta have
it you know it's going to be okay
they're gonna make up it's going to be
all right but that feedback would say oh
no you can't have conflict you know
people don't it turns them off they
don't like it they're gonna turn the TV
they're gonna turn something else on
so we often have to fight to keep
conflict
in in the show in fact if I may even go
a little deeper in the pilot script
originally
um my the way I had written it was that
the uh Melinda the lead was about to get
married and she had not yet told her
husband that she can see ghosts
and so on the eve of her wedding she was
really in tremendous anguish about how
to do this
and she talked at length with his
brother her brother-in-law about what to
do and how to do it and the best way to
approach it you know and and and
the way she finally broke it to him
was she said to him you know I was
talking to your brother last night
and he says my brother's been dead for
five years
and that's how she and the network said
no no we don't want she can't keep him
in the dark
it's not good you always will like it
um you know it's too much conflict
and I was heartbroken it's like you
gotta be kidding me you know what a
great dilemma for this character
so we have to have it he knew from the
beginning he approved of it he was fine
with it
yeah so it was I still managed to get
the brother in there but you know that
was the kind of thing that you know was
difficult um uh to hear and and to
execute
um and again you have to say yourself
you know they're successful they they
know their audience
um you know give it a try but ultimately
as he trusted us more we could push back
a little more against their notes and
and when they saw the result of the
shows they were happy with the show and
the shows were doing well
then they they did you know lean back a
little bit and not be quite as drastic
with your thoughts